in this video I'm going to take a couple
of minutes to tell you about one of our
sponsors it's a company called
box Abel we've talked a ton on this show
about the housing affordability crisis
in the United States and box apples a
company that's actually offering a type
of solution when it comes to certain
aspects of the problem because boxa
building system that lowers build time
and construction costs what they do is
manufacture pre-made homes and buildings
that are built in their factory and
shift in pieces to the site where the
structure will go when it's at the site
it unfolds to create sections of the
structure and multiple boxes can be
connected and stacked to create almost
any residential or commercial building
configuration that you can imagine they
feature large rooms with tons of open
space they have tall 9-foot 6-inch
ceilings they can be delivered in days
you don't have to wait around for months
you have a construction project and
you're using box a bowl this means that
you're spending much less but you're
also keeping your money in your pocket
for much longer they say it takes less
than half as much time to build as
traditional housing and there's also
zero waste at the construction site
everything that gets shipped is part of
the structure itself they say that the
homes are disaster resistant fire rated
wind rated hurricane rated and
earthquake rated all of their structures
are also completely mold proof and the
event of a flood the material doesn't
warp there's no swelling no rotting
every building is also extraordinarily
energy efficient saving occupants forty
to sixty percent annually on energy
costs and reducing the size of the HVAC
equipment that you need as well bak
scible is currently setting up their
first manufacturing facility in Las
Vegas they plan to begin early stage
production by the end of this year
they're also raising capital right now
for the next stage of their
manufacturing facility check out
everything box Abul is doing it's a
fascinating company very novel and a
creative solution to a jewelled problems
you can find them at boxa bold
calm that's Bo X ABL calm I've also put
a link right underneath this video